chipper is a all-inclusive financial
platform that really is aimed at being
intertwined in the fabrics of people's
financial lives living in africa it
includes being able to send peer-to-peer
payments across borders
being able to invest in assets like
crypto or u.s fractional stocks being
able to use visa cards on online
payments as well as interact with
businesses via our api and b2b sort of
products
[Music]
we're in ghana nigeria uganda rwanda
south africa we also live in the u.s and
the uk
nigeria uganda are two of the biggest
markets but all the markets are growing
very very quickly
i think it was born out of both of our
experiences growing up in africa i'm
born and raised in uganda and making
this one raised in ghana and we met in
college and one thing that really
brought us together was this idea that
we've grown up seeing first hand many
problems people face living in africa
and one of the biggest the most
prevalent one to us was sending money
and how difficult that was
you see how easy it is to venmo someone
money but then it's literally impossible
to send money from ghana to uganda the
cost of doing it is more than the amount
that you want to send and so we started
specifically with these we would solve
an intra-african payments we started in
uganda and ghana expanded to nigeria
kenya rwanda and and that's where the
biggest value is and now we're expanding
to the u.s and the uk um because of the
same same cost when i moved to the us as
a student my dad had to figure out how
to send me money from ghana to the us
and that was just a ridiculous process
and involve like informal people sending
back and forth
but with chipper it's significantly
easier you can move very low value
instantly and and almost for free
you have some countries that are
predominantly mobile money based of
mobile money-centric financial services
like uganda kenya a lot of east africa
has gone quite far with mobile money and
then in west africa i think bank
accounts are more prevalent and that's
the predominant financial instrument for
most people
and then there's still a very large
number of people who still don't have
access to any of those solutions so
typically referred to as
unbanked or under-backed and
you sort of factor that in with the fact
that there's 54 different currencies in
africa so there is a cross currency
issue as well
irrespective if you have the right
infrastructure to support money moving
you have to handle the illiquidity of
those currencies and you know a
multitude of other issues but those are
sort of the big ones so you sort of put
that together
it creates a situation where it's very
hard and expensive to
move money from one system in one
country to another
solving the problem
required to kind of solving all those
pieces separately and hence that's kind
of one made it difficult and to this day
i think it's still very difficult and
it's still a long way to go in solving
each of those pieces
when we met at grinnell there was a
instant realization that we both wanted
to do something you know for our home
base for our home continent i mean we
both wanted to solve a really hard
problem so one of the you know apps that
we worked on while at school was voice
which was a
voice messaging app that you send a
voice message and self-destructs upon
receipt
it was a fun project but it got a bond
and it got us started working together
and then over time we've been in touch
and and eventually came up with chipper
we're definitely naive in the beginning
and you know i think the first
time i tried to raise money we tried to
do it with just a deck before we had
built a product but it was a very nice
deck and we thought that this could get
us you know a couple million dollars and
we had a very
early
sort of
you know reality check
and uh i think one of the things that uh
became very clear very early on is that
this is going to be very difficult and
we have to figure out ways to get out of
the gate before we get money so we had
to be creative about how we spent our
resources
um and that you know also how we
tailored our message to different
audiences uh you know in the early days
i thought that if i sort of focused most
on the mostly on
african investors that would be an
easier path and actually end up being a
more difficult path and then i focus
more on silicon valley based investors
and that eventually with some traction
had a bit more success
but in the very beginning that was a
very
tough process trying to attract capital
we've raised a tremendous amount of
money you know hundreds of millions of
dollars
so far and that's an immense
responsibility that people entrust us
with such significant amounts of money
to invest and use
in a manner that we see fit and i think
it's good to have some pressure i think
it sort of keeps you on your toes it
reminds you of the importance of what
you're doing not that you forget but
it's just that
additional reminder to you know be that
much more diligent and much more
thoughtful
the opportunity is getting clearer and
clearer african is the last frontier um
the demographic is incredibly young
people are getting much more tech
enabled
and smartphones on the rise and so
people are realizing like you could
begin a service and you could own the
space and you could grow this content
for the next decade and beyond
and that's that data comes to life which
previously it wasn't but as it starts to
come out to life it's going to attract
more talent more resources and i think
it's going to be exciting they're 1.3
billion people and there's just a lot of
problems that need to be solved
[Music]